من اسطنبول ينظم الى حسين اوروج نائب رئيس
هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه مرحبا بك سيد
اوروج حدثنا عن طبيعه مهمتكم والمشاريع
التي تقومون بها الان على الارض
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه في المرحله
الراهنه
منذ يوم الزلزال نحن متواجدين على الارض
لدينا فريقين يمثلان منظمتنا الفريق الاول
هو فريق الانقاذ حوالي
1500 شخص مجهزين ومدربين بشكل جيد اذا هم
موجودين على الارض
ولدينا ايضا
عمل كبير من قبل هذا الفريق حيث تم انقاذ
حوالي ثلاثمات شخص من الانقاض
وهؤلاء متفرقون على مجموعه من المواقع في
المناطق المنكوبه ورغم انقضاء ازيد من
اسبوع على الزلزال ما زلنا نتمسك
بالكثير من الامال لانقاذ المزيد ايضا
لدينا فريق
للمتطوعين حوالي 2000 شخص متطوعين من اجل
تقديم العون للناجين وللجرحى وهو موجودون
في مختلف
الاماكن المنكوبه لدينا توزيع وتنسيق
لتوزيع المعونات
والمساعدات ان كانت طبيه او غذائيه او حتى
اغ وقايه الناس من البرد وتقديم
الوجبات الساخنه اذا هناك عمل على مستويات
مختلفه لدينا ايضا عمل في سوريا لان سوريا
تاثرت بشكل كبير نحن نقدم دعم بالنسبه
لاخواننا السوريين دعم على مستوى الاغاثه
وايضا نقدم لهم العون على مستوى تقديم
الخدمات الطبيه والغذائيه ارسال
غذائيه لاخواننا في سوريا بعد
الزلزال بيومين او ثلاث جاء الكثير من فرق
الدعم والانقاذ والبحث الانقاذ من العالم
العربي من الدول الخليج ومن دول اخرى اذا
اليوم التنسيق هو افضل بشكل كبير ووكالات
التابعه اللي هي الحكومه والمؤسسات
المنظومه الغير حكوميه تعمل يدا في يد
وتنسق العمل الاغ بشكل جيد واعتقد ان
ان الكل ينتظر انهاء عمليه
الاغاثه والبحث الانقاذ من اجل الانتقال
الى المرحله الثانيه مرحله اعاده البناء
نحن نعرف ان هناك تدني كبير لدرجه الحراره
في بعض المناطق حوالي عشر درجات تحت السفر
وحتى فرق الانقاذ تعمل من دونك وهي تشعر
بالتعب لكنها تواصل العمل على الارض من
اجل تقديم العون المنكوب
تحدثت عن الوكالات التابعه للحكومه
السوريه التركيه التي تعمل على الارض
تحدثت عن منظمات غير حكوميه ايضا التي
تساهم في عمليه الانقاذ والاغاثه وقلت بان
هناك مساعدات ارسلتموها الى سوريا لكن
الاخبار الوارده من شمال السوري
لا تفيد بعدم او تفيد بنوع من الشك الاول
وعدم الاقتناع بحجم المساعدات التي
تلقونها هناك انتم من خلال تجربتكم ما
الذي يعيق وصول المساعدات الى شمال سوريا
ما هي طبيعه المشاكل التي تواجهكم في هذا
الاطار
نحن موجودون داخل الاراضي السوريه منذ عشر
سنوات ونقدم الدعم
لاخواننا في سوريا منذ فتره طويله وهناك
تضامن كبير ونحن نعطي نفس قدر الاولويه
بالنسبه لي اخواننا في بعض المناطق في
سوريا تضررت بشكل كبير وعدد القتلى حوالي
5000 وعدد الجراحه اكثر من ذلك بكثير
والموارد محدوده طبعا ايضا نحن ينبغي ان
ناخذ بمسؤولياتنا وعلى المجموعه الدوليه
ايضا ان تاخذ مسؤوليتها في هذا الخصوص
هناك مناطق كثيره في سوريا تدرجت بشكل
كبير ونحن
نحاول تقديم
على قدر المستطاع بالنسبه للمجتمع الدولي
فهو مطالب بلعب دور اكبر
ونحن ابلغنا
الامم المتحده وطلبنا من روسيا لفتح كل
المعابر روسيا موجوده على الارض
وتمسك بزمامه الامور وعليها ان تفسح
المجال امام القوافل القوافل المساعده من
اجل الدخول الى سوريا ومبدا
اخواننا السوري بالعون الضروري على مجلس
الامن ايضا ان يتحرك وهو قام باجتماع في
الاونه الاخيره من اجل فتح المعابر لادخال
المساعدات
لاخواننا السوريين طبعا تركيا لديها
حاجيات اغاثيه عاجله لكن هذا لا ينبغي ان
يجعلنا ننسى
في سوريا نحن نعاني على من نفس الكارثه
ونحن نعاني بنفس القدر ما نحتاجه في تركيا
يحتاج ايضا اخواننا هناك في سوريا نحن
بحاجه للاغطيه للغداء بحاجه لي الخيام
ونفس الشيء بالنسبه لاخواننا في سوريا
تضررت بناء التحتيه الاساسيه وهذا ايضا
يحتاجون في سوريا شكرا لك يا حسين اوروج
نائبه رئيس هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه من